en voyant ces images difficile de croire
que l'hiver approche
malgré les températures plutôt fraîches
les vélos sont encore de sortie une
aubaine pour cette agence de location
habituellement fermée à cette période de
l'année
c'est assez inhabituel d'avoir des
demandes comme ça en fin octobre
là c'est vrai qu'il fait beau on est on
est là on a les vélos donc au loup on
rend service aux gens qui veulent se
promener on sait qu'il ya beaucoup
d'animations qui sont fermées dans le
coin ces périodes là pour nous c'est
assez facile de faire plaisir aux gens
une arrière saison qui a surpris
beaucoup de commerçants jusqu'au week
end dernier
ce bar de chablis a tourné à plein
régime on a quand même bénéficié de la
météo pour tout ce qui est oui qu'est
mais semaine
on espère quand même un peu de un peu de
pluie mais mais pas trop côté hôtels
pas de grand rush au niveau des
réservations mais une chose est sûre
l'année a été très bonne cet été on a eu
beaucoup plus de réservations que les
années précédentes en particulier des
gens qui viennent du nord de l'europe
beaucoup d'anglais je pense que c'est au
moins 15% de plus que les autres années
maintenant l'activité hôtelière au
niveau touristique est la même que les
années précédentes n'est pas mauvaise
n'est pas supérieur aux années
précédentes mais ça reste tout à fait
respectable un retour à la normale qui
devrait se confirmer dans les prochains
jours avec l'arrivée de la pluie et de
températures de plus en plus fraîches
pour la bourgogne l'été indien semble
définitivement terminée